[Music]
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
good morning before we get even into the
show
grab the URL if you're watching on
Twitter hit that retweet button grab the
URL share on Facebook big shout out to
LinkedIn you can share too there's a
link you can see it
twitch Pham I don't know what you guys
can do but I know you can do something
amazing and everybody who's watching on
Instagram through the live big shout out
great to see you
but Facebook share share share share
share a lot of love a lot of good stuff
let's get into the comments prestonby on
che good to see you
voiceover Donny great to see you I mean
good to see you Naveen
I mean sync buddy good to see you good
to see you James law see the whole whole
crew in here doesn't how you doing this
morning big shout out Foss very good
good that's some good sleep get some
solid sleep yeah yesterday I didn't I
had like one hour what day before yeah I
just couldn't fall asleep some reason it
was bad he was gonna poke Pokemon any
better
unfortunately no Parker snare one of the
great gym teachers of all time
hey Gary on here of course Paul how are
you I'm doing awesome I appreciate your
messaging it's helped me be a better dad
a dentist and my company dental nachos
bye have a special person the most
important person to me I want to come
out have on and say thanks to you real
quick please hey Jeremy how are you
great
so nice to meet you nice to meet you as
well merry nacho just wanted to thank
you for being such an inspiration to our
company but also us personally we love
your message on kindness and you're just
awesome
I think so I wish you well awesome
so Gary we I found at dental nachos our
Facebook group is 25,000 members
hopefully they're watching in your
patients can wait guys for five minutes
so one of the things that I have a
challenge with with dental nachos well
first actual want to thank you for the
best thing that happened during the
pandemic about a year ago I was at the
beach in New Jersey I'm a 42 year old
from New Jersey and I signed up for your
community text platform and I said I
need this for dental nachos by sea Gary
Vee has it Mark Cuban my favorite
comedian Sebastian Maniscalco but I made
a little thing for you here in Philly in
the movie Philadelphia explain it to me
like I'm a four-year-old so gratitude +
patience + kindness + document not
produce equals success because we were
patient and a month ago we got approved
for community so now I can communicate
with my dental nacho group all the time
so our our community is built on helping
dentists make big life decisions that
dental school ignores you know how to
buy a practice how to find your first
job what I call the circle of dentists
ting life and make sense thanks we built
out this platform a lot like peloton in
person C e-courses
livestream and recorded but everything
shut down right now for in-person and my
challenge for you this morning I think
is a tough one is how do I reach
dentists in caves dentistry is a cave
profession means we're isolated or
stressed we're in our own islands and
the 50-plus crew we have a Facebook page
Instagram LinkedIn I even joined tik-tok
all these different platforms but how
would you reach the 50-plus audience for
Dell notches I mean it's email LinkedIn
and Facebook which interesting about
dentist and a reason I'm on here and
always lead with gratitude is one of my
sponsors iris was on the 4 DS I was
walking around Philadelphia I said hey
that's my sponsor and I just to show
your strategies pay off so they called
me at use told them to bring their
dentist content that had nothing to do
with their product so they interviewed
me and I said you don't have to pay me
but you just got to get me an intro to
Gary Vee and Mike Wong I want to thank
him for doing that but what's
interesting about Dennis thanks is that
they they don't really use a lot of like
my dad was a dentist work from with 11
for 11 years before he passed away
unfortunately he was an awesome dad but
he never really used email or LinkedIn
because dentists are this craft
I get it I get it I mean look if you
can't read if they're if if someone's
unreachable they're unreachable like you
know if you need to do direct mail if
you need to drive to their practices
like that's just part of the game I
would argue that an enormous percentage
of dentists even the old-school dentists
are at least now on email right you know
that I I agree then we had a nacho nacho
delivery team that went around
Philadelphia and surrounding areas and
would drop off nachos fun for the office
because a lot of times their team gets
them involved I would also argue that
the 50 year old doesn't need your
service the way you pitched it as much
because you know they could have used it
25 years ago it probably would have an
epic for them but I would argue that
Instagram and tic toc focusing on the 18
to 22 year old in-school dentist is just
a fart a lot of times people over value
someone they can't get an under value
the opportunity on something they're
getting yeah you see where I'm going
like it might take the same energy to
get one [ __ ] fifty nine-year-old
dentist as it does to get eighty-eight
dental students and by the way that you
positioned it at least by the way I just
heard it for me it makes so much sense
for a 21 26 19 year-old dentist and just
want to be to have this be part of their
life more than the 57 year old who's
already kind of like figured a lot of
that out it's a good I mean well a lot
of what we talk about our dentists and
Cora Joe heard you talk about soft
tissue yesterday or the day before so we
talked about developing your core of
your mind how you speak and your
clinical hand skills so that's really
resonating with people even before
dental school but in this circle of
dentists ting life
the older dentist needs the babysitter
they need the associate or the dentist
to come in and work with them so they
can get more time off and that's leading
to some of the stress so I'm trying to
figure out a way to connect them I mean
look I think Direct Mail print four or
five page pamphlet with a huge URL I
mean you know even the most old-school
can go to youtube so I think if you if
you say look text us now that you have
community Texas at this like the front
of the pants
but I would have like a huge phone
number and say look Texas any question
will answer it any question yeah um I
like that you see where I'm going and
then maybe a very simple URL like maybe
you get a URL like you know you know
nacho dentist comm slash watch something
or just something very simple those two
on the front of four-part four-page
pamphlet direct mail to their to their
you know office
I still think you can also get a lot
done on on Facebook and LinkedIn more
than you would think
well we re we have that Facebook group
of twenty thousand people we have that's
a very that's very different than
running an ad to 50 to 90 year olds in
South Jersey Philly area with with the
ad being do you know anybody who's a
dentist who's a 45 year old dentist or
older and they're passing on that video
that's a very different execution than
having a group I like they are nacho
stars the fifth year olds that are in
the group are saying things like I wish
I had this when I was a young dentist
maybe I can get one of them to star in
that Facebook ad for me so to learn or
or you can start a referral program
where whatever the economics are in your
business you give a 25 percent lead gen
ste to the 50 year olds and they just
start getting all their own friends
Dennis do like stuff like that I know my
dentist people they will enjoy that
that's awesome and there's one last
thing as the leader of a company kind of
working with me is like working with a
friendly tornado I have a lot of new
ideas so how do you not overwhelm your
team with too many new ideas while
they're still working on your existing
ideas by not judging them when they're
not executing on certain ideas they're
gonna like hearing that they're watching
in they're really gonna enjoy here and
you say you know I throw a ton at my
team and then three weeks later recall
something I threw at them and it hasn't
even started and I have empathy because
I know they're going super hard so it's
it's it's you continue with your ideas
it's that you need to make sure that
you're not burning them out and judging
them too much and I think you do that
with kindness when it hasn't started
it's understanding you know one of our
clips that you did is I I changed my
mind I changed my mind they play that
all the time in del nachos I say see
Gary Vee does that so I Bri
and I had Mark Evans on garyvee I sent
him this shirt a notch I don't have at
your at headquarters you have at least
50 of these somewhere that we say one
down
so I really appreciate Kari take your
pop thanks so much let's keep going some
good information there hope everybody
enjoyed that let me start a Lewis house
all great to see you Mike Dreams what's
up with you
Garrett Glen yes I need to hear that
thank you you are welcome one of the
great things about tea with Gary Vee is
how many the answers actually resonate
for people that are watching
let's also continue to share share share
please share this on Facebook and
Twitter on the retweet or the share
button on LinkedIn share button or grab
the URL and post it I want to get some
newbies in here newbies are fun let's
keep it moving hey Gav he has a gun I'm
great Martin how do you pronounce your
name kosher kosher such a pleasure it's
the honor to meet you man I've been
following you for about six and a half
seven years now Luke wait wait wait were
you from I'm from Birmingham Alabama I
was born in New Orleans my parents were
from India but I was born in the States
fantastic what could answer for you so
first of all I obviously do have some
questions but more so than the questions
the main reason I've reached out was I
really wanted to start a relationship
but you really wanted to just build and
get to really ultimately you've impacted
my life more than you'll ever know so
just being on the show and being able to
talk to you is mean that means a lot to
me it started off I you know run a
social media agency or a team about 25
people I've been doing this for about
six years now we shifted to a social
media agency back in 2016 so I've been
doing that for about four years the name
of the social media agency is socially
and we're basically grooming mmm so I've
you know talked to tons and tons of
members of your team Scott who was
actually a member of Manor back in the
day with your CFO he was actually a
mentor to us I'm still as a mentor to us
and now I've talked with James in the
social group we even worked with Jesse
out of Maine or Chattanooga and you know
I've just you know we've been around
your circle for a very long time but one
of the main things at the social media
agency that you know we've had issues
with is
we've had opportunities to talk to you
know fortune 500 clients fortune 100
clients but for some reason we just
can't get past a certain barrier on
whether it's they look at us as a too
small in the shop whether we don't have
the recognition you know we don't go out
there and win the awards that these big
agencies doing it since we focused
strictly on social we produce content we
know we'll do the influence or manage
the platform's community match and run
ads all of that or we will only do
social we don't dabble into the whole
digital space and I think sometimes that
sizes away from big brands so that's an
issue we've been having as far as like
getting in front of the door or getting
even the introduction and it is a couple
things one the market absolutely has
involved you know we're not when I
started selling social in 2009 didn't
even know what it was so the thought of
somebody to being a specialty I think
they one of the ways to think about big
brands is there's a term in big brands
called orphan brands small brands they
give no money to and and they're usually
big brands that we all know but they're
just the proctor or Unilever a Pepsi
they're like right 8/18 biggest brand
which is like a huge rupee or that we
all know or a huge pasta sauce we all
know but small in their world couple you
know hundreds of millions of dollars in
sales not billions right 50 million I
think that's a place where you could win
a scope so I think getting educated on
on that part of the portfolio and then
when you go in for the pitch you solely
focus on that you're not getting Pepsi
you're not getting Coke right now it's
just not where it's at so I think you go
I think you go there and I also think
about you know look take it from
somebody who does business with that
like you know with Boehner and Sasha
there's a lot of great things to be
focused on the small and mid market um
you know clients and I think sometimes
ego is what drives people to want to do
the big brands the budgets are bigger
but the profit isn't necessarily bigger
you know there and and the vulnerability
is enormous you know when you get fired
from a big brand sometimes it's an
enormous percentage of your business so
I would I would focus on orphan brands I
would also you know and I did this I
would also consider doing it for free
yeah and we've pitched that 100% you
never watched a long time so we've done
it even produce free content we had this
concept of where we literally pitch
ideas of we did this for Dick's Sporting
Goods because there used to be one of
our clients so we would just pitch a
content buffets a bunch of different
ideas we don't price them in whatever
they like we'll do it for them at a
price that we negotiate I think I think
the other thing you focus on is you take
advantage of where you're located I
think I really focus on South East you
know
mid what like I think you play in the
middle I would really focus on those
middle companies Minnesota even Chicago
definitely companies that are in
Nashville I would really focus on those
companies as well okay so we've done one
thing that I want to mention is shows
outside of you know socially in a part
of socially in which will lead to my
second question is we've started a vent
business where we actually have a social
media event once a year it's called the
southern social summer so we it's in
Birmingham it's gonna be in Atlanta
eventually because we're moving to
Atlanta but essentially it's a vent
around social media just educating the
community about how what they can be
doing on social media how they can help
their business even if you are freelance
or what they can be doing to help the
freelancing business and just really
educational don't really make money too
much money out of it but we just want to
promote it but we had about 500 people
last year and this year it'll be digital
obviously because of kovat so we're
expecting it to be a lot bigger so
outside of that second question I had
was we wanted an idea that we had was we
want to do a staffing agency strictly
around social media jobs smartly to
tailor smart we we think a lot about
lean or recruiting I'm surprised I
haven't launched it yet I mean people
just desperately need better talent and
so I think there's something there okay
because I saw it from one of some of
your intern program where they would get
other jobs at major ages hundred percent
yes like that's amazing that and the
empathy that you had to show like I
built this person they showed them what
they got and they're able to go out
there and do what they love that's
amazing you know yeah that one less one
less thing I know you have a bunch of
people that talk to that leads me to one
last thing about things that
and the main thing that I really wanted
to talk to you about was I I am one
thing you talk about on your content was
people that make very little money you
know fifty sixty thousand dollars but
they are really happy and they're able
to show that and but and by the way
fifty to sixty thousand is not very
little money and I know where you're
going
this is not a razz is more of a
conversation it's it's that that I'm
focused on which is which is everybody
thinks about a millionaire everybody
thinks for the bottom of kind of doing
something's a hundred thousand when the
medium incomes forty thousand you know
like so like you know
yeah I'm fascinated about happiness but
go ahead I'm sorry so I put out content
obviously as not as much as you say so
you looking at look at my social media
publish it on me but ultimately um when
I put out this happiness I'm showing
them I do I do right now I preach about
how happy I am I don't have tons and
tons of mayonese money in the value of
society or what society thinks it's
success but ultimately my happiness
successes and I put that out there but
how can people how can i and maybe they
don't need to listen but how can I make
them listen or show them that outside of
just saying happiness is it that that's
what really matters
99.9999% of the world doesn't listen to
me that's your answer well it's not
about making people listen is more of a
subconscious self Estelle fish act it's
like you do the right thing you know
somebody on Twitter said this is really
cool that Gary B's doing this when it's
time like alright you do the right thing
and you just move right like like I get
it and I am I like I like people being
selfish they should care about
themselves in their family I also think
sometimes it's really great to just it's
kind of like of course all lives matter
but let's focus on black lives right of
course of course we should be selfless
and be kind people but it's okay
sometimes to be self selfish and it's
okay sometimes to be 100% selfless you
know one of the things I think that
really works for me is when I make my
content I'm in completely the mindset of
selflessness you know so many people
like you know what are you doing with
teeth Gary you know are you doing tea
with Gary B what's the what's the
strategy there like to help people what
yeah to bring value to like you know
cold Cove it's heavy the times are heavy
in the you know coming in the morning
you know to me 9:00 to 10:00 a.m. is the
worst time like the day has started it's
I feel anxiety I also know it's a great
time for a lot of people because it
gives them that pep that can cause you
know last question because I know the
first two were a little bit selfish you
know I'm running my business but
ultimately I was also thinking how can I
help the audience that's watching I
believe by doing it yeah just do it just
do it I'll sock you said let me back say
well our YouTube Dustin I literally
slept 10 hours last night jealous and
somebody and somebody in the comments
was like you look tired Gary and I'm
like man cuz everybody thinks you know
you know this I'm a big fan of sleep but
I talk a lot about going hard while
you're awake yeah but I always I always
think about like DNA like I've got the
hard court Eastern European like like no
matter like even when I was like 19 like
this bag thing under my eyes that I
always like and my skincare routine is
all-time worst I think I was like what
wash my face once so like you know like
it's just really funny because when I
see that stuff I'm like wait TC what up
because of my uncle my grandfather
pictures I'm like wait to see me in ten
years keep going
whether what our primary what's done
it's so funny cuz I like the whole gang
of people watching because I've been
like manifesting this moment for like
the past couple bucks and telling my
friends everyday like yeah wait I get on
TV with Gary Vee so they're all like
watching today so you were excited about
the newbies so like there's a whole gang
of people that are like it's good to be
here today so I have a couple of
questions just to like quick ones if
that's okay um so a little backstory um
when I was twenty I kind of like dropped
out of college and then I got pregnant
my son and me and a few of my friends I
asked them if they like wanted to start
this mom group and so we kind of started
this mom group and turned it into a
non-profit and it like really blew up
and it was like this amazing thing and a
lot of fun and probably like still one
of my greatest accomplishments um
and code would kind of took that and
like put it to a halt like we couldn't
meet we couldn't do anything and I
actually like I guess like in that time
period so over the last like a couple
months I kind of found like a new
passion
um and so I started doing like DIY
projects and like furniture flips and
stuff like that um so I ended up yeah so
it's been really cool and like people
are like really into it and so like I
don't know I guess I kind of feel bad
about like abandoning like my old
passion but also um you can't have a pop
you can a pop you can't apologize for
the truth true that do that it was kind
of becoming more like a chore rather
than like you know something that I was
like more excited to do and by the way
not everything in life has to be so
absolutely that's like the biggest
problem right now and in our society
everything's like you're bad you're good
everything's so binary and there's like
no room for like a little compromise and
and that's what I think about your
situation right now you don't have to
completely bounce on the moms group you
could just turn it into something that
you check in once a month on or it's an
every six week thing now instead of an
everyday thing that is true we do run
like a private group that's still up and
people still like
device and things like that in there
okay and you can make a video and hop in
there and say or write right in there I
don't know how its structured and be
like yo listen I'm evolving this is what
I'm about right now but this is forever
something I love and I'm gonna come here
every six weeks and I'm gonna hang for
three hours and any you know anything
that I was bringing to the table before
if I could bring during that time we're
good
sure that you that I'm so to expand like
a little bit more on that like um I
guess like my personality as a whole
it's like I'm kind of like a giver so
like I feel like I like give give give
like constantly and I thought you're a
giver too like how do you cuz like I
give my all at work all day I come home
I had two kids so I like you know give
my all to them my friends my family like
just constantly like and then you know
like after they go to bed I'm trying to
like work on this like new passion and
like how do you how do you find the
balance because I know that you're like
a giver to like how do you pour from an
empty cup like at the end of the day
it's not everything because and it's
probably this is what works for you too
like the giving is your energy right
like when I give I feel alive and when I
give I don't expect anything in return
so that some rarely disappointed from
the giving and then I think that's the
last layer of that cake is I don't judge
myself like if I go three months and I
want to get something done and it's not
progressing because I'm because I've got
nothing in the cup because I gave too
much over the last hundred days then
that's okay but that's happening a lot
to me right now like you know between
you know the business and making sure
family and friends are okay and between
the all-in challenge were raised almost
sixty million dollars and between you
know just there's just some you know
being there for so many friends that are
really struggling right now so many
friends you know contemporaries and you
know acquaintances are struggling you
know just heavy right like yesterday
there was that report about like the pig
flu and China and just like some my
friends are just like I give up and I'm
like okay relax you know that's you know
when you're when you're the emotional
strength for a lot of people it's
daunting but and so what ends up
happening is if I didn't get to
something over the last three weeks six
weeks that I needed to financially
professionally emotionally
I just know it's okay I think a lot of
people beat themselves up like I can see
you being like damn I didn't register my
daughter for camp I [ __ ] up or [ __ ]
like you know like and I'm kind of like
you know like I'm just trying out here
and I think I think it's self-love and
it's being practical about you know when
you're giving all day sometimes
something's gonna drop coming I think I
think balance is in the eye of the
beholder
you know everyone's like gotta get that
work/life balance down I'm like that's
individual yeah everyone's got a
different point of view on work like
that and I'm all over the place right
like last night I slept 10 hours you
know we could go or last week I'd stand
up to two o'clock in the morning and
looked up sports cards and woke up at
6:00 you know like like I just don't
think life is binary as people think it
is you know and I'm just comfortable
navigating it you know Michelle um okay
so my other question so like you know
I've been into the flipping and all of
that so I started a page called like
this simple flipping life this is
supposed to be about like you know
minimalism and then like taking what you
have and kind of flipping it and DIY
renovations and things like that um but
I already kind of like naturally had
like a little bit of a following like on
my personal pages and so like I was kind
of torn between like should I just like
do it on my personal pages okay I was
like I don't know like cuz I don't know
if I said okay so like my end goal is to
like flip house mates and to show people
how to flip houses so I I don't know if
I should build anything around that too
or like just never the brand christened
the brand is you look at your hand on
life is Kristin life ain't one [ __ ]
dimension you read about the [ __ ] you
already got the name I'm putting out
wine I'm putting out sports cards I'm
put out business and put out garage
sales I'm putting out all sorts of [ __ ]
on my platform people people really
think it's a niche game I don't I mean
everyone's got a different point of view
but like I don't see it that way
you know I really don't and I think I
think I mix it all and some people like
and people
when I went from can you imagine this
when I started talking about business on
my page after I did Wine content for
three years before I did any business
content everybody was just yelling at me
like you know
stay in your lane wine boy you're not
don't talk about business like people
just you know like this isn't gonna work
you're gonna fail like stick to what you
know and I was laughing I'm like you
don't know me I know a ton of [ __ ] and
you know a ton of [ __ ] you're gonna have
different interests cuz I can tell the
way you're talking and that's [ __ ]
amazing
that's what makes it interesting thank
you thank you not sure those people that
were hating in the comments are probably
still hating God listen
hate is the byproduct of somebody who's
unhappy with their own life we should
stop hating our haters we should start
loving our haters yeah I mean I have a
crazy relationship with the people that
hate me I actually have incredible
amounts of compassion and sympathy and
empathy like the thought to take time
out of my day to try to drag somebody
else down or make them feel bad that
blows my mind I've got zero zero seconds
for that [ __ ] like I'm trying to spend
every second I tend to make people happy
and feel good I can't even imagine can't
even imagine the deep insecurities the
bad parenting the the unlucky
circumstances the pain I mean to really
want to go to somebody to really want to
go to somebody's [ __ ] account and try
to make them feel awful - and notice how
the key word there was - yeah there's
nobody who's happy and content who's
going into the comments hating we're
gonna need to find a way to be
compassionate
I see people blocking and deleting hate
don't block and delete that's your own
insecurity of you not being able to deal
with something that might be making you
feel uncomfortable I mean this is this
is about going to a higher place I I
roll with deep compassion for my haters
you have time to worry about my life
when I don't even know your name that's
not good
III want it to be better for you they
say if you don't have me haters and
you're not doing something right - so
but that's again that's that street talk
to like pump someone up I'm coming at it
from a from love talk I'm coming at this
from a totally different place I don't
need haters or cheers to tell me I'm win
and I know I'm winning I don't need any
[ __ ] validation from the outside pro
or con I'm actually talking about
genuinely genuinely caring about other
human beings especially the ones that
are most trying to hurt you that's on
some different mental [ __ ] and that's
and that is what I think is the next
step that we need my fiance was like
he's not gonna follow you I might do
Gary's totally gonna follow me what's
his name and his name is Brayton
elevator what's his name
Branton Brampton yeah lost this one bro
thanks bro I got you man you got it you
got a real page going good for you that
was like I just already trying to like
that was like naturally just my page
like like literally I probably posted
like five times in like the past two
days because I knew I was gonna be all
right here until I was like I have to
get it together but the rest of that is
literally just like I literally just
started trying to time they all says
Gary Vee made me do it - I love it
I love it I wish you well take care hey
do I man that was a good little moment
there I've been really thinking a lot
about this there's so much anxiety and
hate right now in the world
we're on tilt and people are just
looking to fight looking a teardown
looking to blame somebody it's just it's
a real real real heavy time and
there is only one answer only which is
compassion empathy and you know that
doesn't mean there aren't systemic
things that need to change and things I
made sure but people are people are
selling fear or they're selling judgment
right now everything is fear or judgment
and me that you know fear or shame
excuse me it's fear of shame right now
it's a [ __ ] fear or shame just not
working let's keep it moving hold air a
Gary Vee good morning hey Brandon how
are you I'm pretty good pretty good
- great we'll free offering these
interaction experiences man there's so
much uncertainty in these transitional
times of self growth and I've gained so
much insight motivation and value from
your content so - thank you very much
gotcha awesome as a it's gonna ask you
just one question as a 35 year old
departing a life of hospitality and
restaurants I'm inspired to sort of like
sample the waters as you say - a lot of
20 year olds and I'm asking how do I
know she ate the feelings that you know
I don't have enough time to try these
new things out that I need a fast track
my progress with boot camps and
certifications sort of to compensate for
lost time and need to make a decision
like immediately no you're wrong
it's good to hear like I'm 34 years old
I started my life all over and had
nothing you know a lot of people are
very confused by my story I came into my
dad's business I worked my [ __ ] face
off
from 22 to 34 I built that from a three
to a sixty million dollar business me I
never got paid more than 100k because in
family businesses you just kind of put
all the money back in the business right
and then I left at 34 and had dick
because it was my mission to give back
to my parents I was proud to build that
business for my parents but I left was
nothing I love when people try to throw
hate back to last thing like [ __ ] this
guy his dad gave him three million
dollars I'm in and out of business doing
three million dollars top-line revenue
not profit I [ __ ] went in there and
built it for 20
left with zero and at 34 started
vaynermedia with AJ six months before my
35th birthday and had no money to the
point where I had to get a friend big
shout out my class around from bloody
media to let our office be in one of his
conference rooms because we couldn't
afford rent hmm crazy okay now now just
to put the full clarity for everybody I
because I was making 40 60 70 80
thousand a year in my 20s and that
because and I lived what I give it my
son I saved my money I had a dog [ __ ]
[ __ ] car and a dog [ __ ] clothes I
didn't go out I didn't do [ __ ] I saved
and so then at 32 when Facebook and
Twitter and Tumblr came along I was able
to take the money and put it all in that
and bet the farm on it which is why I
had no money I was saving hmm but then
right before we start a vein or a couple
a year earlier to I put all that money
to work on this big risk I was taking
than everybody said I was crazy on on
Facebook Tumblr and Twitter that
obviously worked out so I eat dog [ __ ]
for a decade which gave me the savings I
lived that $65,000 a year life you know
and then I put into work and I made the
right bet um the point that stories
really to tell you that like I basically
started over at 34 okay yeah so when I
hear people worried at 26 and warty 20
now I came with my experience I had the
experience of learning how to build a
business cuz I [ __ ] had Talent but
most people that have my kind of talent
from 22 to 34 they're named [ __ ]
LeBron James and they make billions like
like you know or there or there or there
like one of the founders of a company
that sold ton of business I did it for
the family I lived my chaste and and I
don't regret it at the time you know in
my early 30s there was some resentment
you know but but the reality is now it's
the best thing I ever did I do the right
thing by my folks I did the right thing
for my soul and I'm proud of how I did
it and now it allows me to tell you
right at this moment like your child
bro they're cool man what are we talking
about here bro your kid yeah don't
compare when I was 27 years old and
working the Christmas season I had to be
on the floor the store because usually I
would be downstairs or upstairs once we
built a new store and be on the computer
selling wine but during December I had
to go downstairs because it was too busy
and my friends would come that I went to
high school with would come to the
liquor store at the wine store and they
would buy a case of champagne and I
would ring them up at the cash register
cashier and then I would grab the case
and take it outside and put it into
their car their BMW sometimes cuz so my
friends were good students and kind of
went to Wall Street or did some [ __ ] and
and when I tell you there was never a
moment in that entire story I just told
you think about the humility and
patience and confidence that is needed
to to be the stock boy be the cashier
and be the servant that brings out the
box to your high school friends car and
not nd it but use it as motivation as
inspiration as focus so don't worry
about what some 23 year olds doing that
has nothing to do with you that was the
biggest problem of everyone getting so
hyped on sucks or Kevin Systrom or
Travis with uber Instagram and Facebook
they were incredible entrepreneurs and
then transcendent stuff but their life
had nothing to do with you that's the
problem with like the prior conversation
where the wonderful young gentleman said
you know not know Mary little money
fifty sixty thousand fifty sixty
thousand people ripped their arms off
for half the people here watching the
way now when more maybe would would die
to make fifty sixty thousand a year
right but would yeah absolutely because
because because if they're making fifty
eight and they don't like it
is it better to make forty two and love
it like you know to me that's just a
whole game man
listen I'm at the top of my game well on
my way to all-time stuff and I'm like
sitting here debating if I want to
retire and be like quit everything and
just become a baseball card dealer I'm
being dead [ __ ] serious huh if I
didn't love Boehner and
me so much doing all this stuff and I'm
still like having weird thoughts this
week gotcha like I was hanging on some
like on some like real talk
Tasha I'm hearing all of that man I
really appreciate that just saying it's
okay to just let that allow that legroom
to happen in your 30s because cuz the
time these are early bro yeah young [ __ ]
at 44 yeah I don't know what the
pressure is in the thirties game or
something
the pressure is society made rules your
parents your your friend your 36 year
old you know good friend from fifth
grade who's on kid number three and has
a second house like the the the pressure
is envy and caring about other people
instead of focusing on your own [ __ ]
cool cool it's the Joneses yeah yeah I
hear you man awesome really appreciate
that thank you so much Gary talk to see
awesome really appreciate you bro good
luck thank you so much
Dustin yes sir
there's some real [ __ ] Concannon team
Clinton can we get the team to clip some
of this [ __ ] and put on the gram tryin
[ __ ] killin it [ __ ] let's go I am on a
roll so we said Gary's on a roll that's
right let's keep it moving yeah what's
up Gary [ __ ] man I'm [ __ ] nervous man
don't worry bro we're friends like
shaking and everything um I've been
watching you for like three years dude
damn can't even get the nerves in check
right now
what do you like Naples Florida actually
oh my wife is watching my mom is
probably watching - so what's up guys
they know this is like a really big deal
to me man like I said I've been watching
you for like three years and holy [ __ ]
trying to be a man trying to be a man
here bro it doesn't take a man I'm a man
a man owns his emotions I'm a man out
here talking about compassion sympathy
kindness and love so I'm proud of you
for talking about your nerve
and I'm unbeliev I just want you to hear
this clear you can't imagine how nice
that makes me feel I'm super flattered
so I'm so glad it's Holi
you really do change people's lives dude
like I'm sure you know but like it's
like to a whole different level so I
started watching you like three years
ago actually I was like in tech school
um to give you kind of a quick back
story I'm sure to try to be as quick as
I can I'm 22 I'm married I've been
married for like three years I just had
a baby couple like you know in January
cuz you know I'm pretty fulfilled in
that sense you know what I'm saying but
like I'm aspiring like I'm one thing
I've always loved to do since I've been
like 13 is like make youtube videos like
just because like I have had rough
patches of my life when I was younger
and like watching people on YouTube like
you know entertaining people like that's
always been like I'm like wow like you
know it's always made me feel good so
I'm like always like I want to do that
for people too and like my thing is like
I love cars like I like racing I like
you know building racecars and [ __ ] so
like I have a youtube channel that I've
it's been up for like four years but
I've been so inconsistent you know like
I upload and that I delete it because I
think the videos aren't good enough you
know just like really negative and then
that's when I started watching you I
actually like I said like three years
ago I was in tech school and I think I
really went to tech school too because
of like you know I was like I need to
make a normal life out of myself like
you know I was already engaged about to
get married I'm like I need a real
career this and that but then I started
watching you know like man I'm a piece
of [ __ ] like I'm just doing it because
you know like I think that's what I need
but it really doesn't just for clarity
for it just for clarity as long as if
there's some new people watching that
slang term in our world of like we're
doing it the wrong way I think a lot of
times when some of the Jersey jargon
comes out of my mouth like I don't want
people to like think we're demonizing
here like it just means like we're
there's more opportunities so keep going
right yeah like I was like I'm doing all
this I feel like for other people you
know cuz like I was like the bad kid
growing up man I'm telling you I was
like the black sheep of the family you
know like I was bad behaved like
terrible grades in school I'd throw my
report card away before you know I gave
it to my mom
oh [ __ ] my fault
right I literally flushed down the
toilet my report card all the time it
was fun it was a funny game between me
and my mom she knew but I was I was
trying to buy you know was cuz I would
always get punished for usually a month
but my mom would let me off after two
weeks so it was always trying to buy an
extra weekend before of course man like
I was just like you know and basically
like I feel like I went to tech school
and I did all that just to prove myself
and you know just kind of be like you
know I'm not as bad as people think you
know especially when your family says
you're bad it's a kind of rough to deal
with that you know it's extremely
difficult so it's really tough yeah I
thought I was like you know what I'm
gonna do this I graduated with a 4.0
which I know in tech schools like now
it's only a year and a half so it's not
like too big of a deal
bro I tried my best don't bring don't
undermine your success yeah I know just
some people like I'm sure like the
biggest the biggest issue out of your
mouth is the word some people yeah bro
mean you have to stop giving a [ __ ]
about these people in the comments and
the ones that are watching yeah that's
true
no and that's um ready for this let me
tell you about my life some people
thought business what like selling
sports cards as a teenager was gonna
lead to me being a bum because I got bad
grades right though some people are
wrong yeah they're definitely wrong some
people are right some people are wrong
but like but value it like I always
listen very carefully and just like you
hedging the 4.0 based on some people is
the biggest thing we need to work on on
the next 91 years of your life you've
gone nine you know like that's just
that's where you're at you we gotta fix
that yeah
and when I say fix that that feels too
heavy you need to get into a better
relationship with that right everyone's
always gonna have an opinion yeah no I
mean that's that's 100% true everyone
always has something to say and it's I I
thought Patrick mahomes was not gonna be
good quarterback right football doesn't
seem like a whole lot but guess what
he's really good yeah yeah well like
that was like all that basically just
kind of lead-up to you know what I think
about myself like in the sense of so
like I'm a very negative person you know
what I'm saying like I'm a negative
got a guy like literally I will you're
sit you're cynical like you wake up and
you're cynical yes like I wake up and
I'm like what can go wrong today you
know because like I've tried Sears ready
for this you're not a negative person
you're a scared person uh yeah yeah I
could definitely Alexis that's a big
difference bro
for all the people out there that are
watching better fear that are scared and
fear-based and vulnerable you're not
negative don't demonize yourself you're
actually vulnerable
you're not negative bro I didn't think
about it like that actually
I never thought like that's why we're
[ __ ] doing tea with get yes yes I so
I'm glad to be out here let me talk and
let me tell you why this is important
Alexis if you all of a sudden when you
wake up tomorrow and you realize you're
not a negative when somebody thinks
they're a negative person that's
devastating yeah you're like I'm bad no
no you're not bad you're hurt yeah yeah
maybe it was something that happened to
me you know what I was younger or
something you're just kind of like oh
that's that you know where it's like
what's gonna happen today you know like
it's such a bad but like I feel like
that affects me with everything I do
because like when I'm making youtube
videos or like what I'm doing so like
that I'm kind of like you know like all
this is gonna be trashed like this isn't
good enough like you know and just like
I don't know I put myself down a lot and
I'm just like my original question
actually is nothing with what I'm
talking about you know bro this is the
real [ __ ] and like we're here I'm with
you right now
I like this talk right now I really
really really like this talk right now I
think you're helping over the next 10
years cuz a lot of people watch this
video not when we recorded you're about
to help a lot of people I could see in
the comments you literally just helped a
lot of people just in that one moment so
let's keep going I'm telling you that
your self-esteem is vulnerable because
to your point you said it earlier when
your family tells you you're not good
you believe that [ __ ] yeah yeah 100%
100% and I think we need to get out of
that I know and that's really does your
does your does your family still say
that oh I honestly so like as soon as I
started watching your videos and I know
you say not to do this as much but like
I feel like you know I just tried to cut
out negative people out of my life and
just isolate myself like I do this a lot
even like
I've actually never had any long-term
friends like I've never had a friend
that I can be like oh I've been best
friends with this guy for a long time I
think my best friend right now I guess
is like I've known him for like a year
you know what I'm saying because like I
soon as like someone does something well
it's like it makes me feel negative I
just kind of like isolate myself and I
pushed everyone away you know what I'm
saying like of course cuz yours because
you're emotionally soft yeah yeah I can
see that
and your Mendoza line for cutting
someone off is super low like for me my
Mendoza lines super high when you have
to really really really go somewhere and
I've had a lot of things done to me I
had a friend in college who stole my
Sega Genesis and I still was friends
with him after I found out oh [ __ ]
because I because I knew he was in a bad
spot to do that to me I was raised a rug
in college but like but like but like
but other people I know cut people off
because they said something right like
that the reason the reason you don't
have long-term friendships is because of
your own lack of self esteem and your
inability to rise above when somebody
goes low right and like and that was
gonna keep going oh I was just gonna say
like that was gonna be my thing like I
said I've been watching you for a long
time and I know like you know you
actually I was worse than that to be
honest like Waterloo has made me better
like you know more confident myself and
more like you know I can deal with that
kind of stuff more but I feel like it
takes a long time too because even in 3
years of watching you like I'm still not
where I want to be if that makes any
sense like I'm still you know now like
mentally where I want to be it just stop
being so negative and I wish and every
time something good happens in my life
I'm always like okay what's gonna happen
now like I see you can ask my wife like
I don't get excited when good things
happen because I automatically think
something Bad's gonna happen right after
bro I live with this my father's got a
lot of these similar traits bro holy
[ __ ] so I understand you is there any
way like I can you know like get better
at that you know like horse you just
said you got better the last three years
yeah yeah I feel like I have like I feel
like I've gotten better at like stop
fearing about what other people think
about me that's like a big thing for me
like I've gotten way better at that you
know you see how you've got some
some muscle yeah how'd you do that
yeah worked out play football in high
school yeah that's how you do this yeah
listening to positivity owning your
shortcomings except that you know the
reason I'm talking with such candor here
you know I'm sure some people are
watching like the ham Gary's like
exposing his [ __ ] I'm not doing I mean I
like it I love it it's awesome
cuz it's empowering when you own your
shortcomings yeah I don't want to say
that I thought Patrick I mean it's a
silly one but I don't want to say that I
thought Patrick mahomes was gonna throw
too many pics to be a good quarterback
he's gonna he might end up being the
best quarterback in football history
because going on this path like you know
it but but if you can't own your [ __ ]
shortcomings well then you can't talk
about your strikes bro I actually you
know what I think is keeping me here
with you is my deep belief that you're
on your way because it's about awareness
like the fact that you're you're the
fact that you have the strength to come
on here with all these people watching
and talk to me like this actually makes
me believe that you're well on your way
because I know a lot of people who don't
yeah I'm just like trying to like you
know like it's such a bad thing in my
life that like it's like a mental block
for everything I do then it's like man I
need to stop doing this like it's like I
realize like I'm so you know and like
just trying to like you know stop you
you need to realize that you're not bad
you grew up being told you were bad and
you believed it you need to realize
you're not bad you're scared right the
second you go from I'm a bad guy I'm a
tough guy I'm a negative guy too I'm a
soft guy I'm a vulnerable guy I'm
emotionally like not where I need to be
guy all of a sudden the way you even
look at yourself changes and then you
could start focusing on building those
muscles on that yeah you know do you get
this feeling that you don't like you you
get you cut people off because you don't
feel like you get into this place where
you feel like they're pulling one off on
you and you don't like that yes like I
always think somebody has an angle every
time someone's nice to me I'm like okay
what's your anything dude like what do
you offer me
you know what I'm saying did you feel
that way about me the first time you saw
the content potentially like what's
gonna be the other shoe like is he gonna
trying to sell me a course or what's the
[ __ ] punchline
actually do you not remember um
surprisingly I feel like I didn't just
because like you know like you were so
honest that I feel like you wouldn't be
the type to do that you know what I'm
saying like you're just being like
straight-up like authentic and honest
and okay so it really I think maybe
that's because I was remote and through
right screen and step on your life
possibly you know look I I think you
need to here's where you here's where
I'm trying to get you to go you need to
get into a totally different place with
your self-esteem you need to love
yourself that's why the biggest moment
of this talk was you're not negative
you're just vulnerable that was the
right this moment because when you wake
up and you're like I'm scared today
right and and I need to get less scared
today
that is HUGE HUGE
compared to waking up and saying I'm
negative I'm a bad guy that's a
game-changer Alexis that's a
game-changer yeah it's it's like hard
though like I tried to I really like
okay like just stop thinking like that
you know like you got this so it's it's
you have to understand it's ingrained in
you so what you need to do is practice
what do I mean by that the next this one
friend you got right now for a year the
first time he does something that
doesn't pop off properly you have to
[ __ ] you have to like email me or DME
or watch this video game you have to
forgive him right yeah that's yeah that
holds grudges broke grudges are carb
that yeah grudges are [ __ ] garbage
grudges are the execution of a weak man
yeah no I I agree 100% it makes you just
you know makes your life quality go down
when you hold grudges cuz you can't just
pull it is your wife positive
yes she's like the complete opposite of
me yeah course you got try to break here
you're not that bad you're not the bad
bro I'm telling you right now we changed
the terminology in your life [ __ ] we'll
get good you
that bad you're that weak you're that
scared you're that soft I totally agree
with you honestly like it's big I want
to change your vernacular because if you
do you'll be a different man yeah
it's that when you're most scared you
try to bring her down to your level no
it's exactly what I do that's what when
you say you talk about like haters you
know like trying to bring other people
down do you find you find yourself like
being jealous if like another guy looks
at her like are you trying to like cage
her no not like that like I'm not like
bad like that but I'm bad in the sense
of like when she's like trying to be
happy for me for something I
accomplished you're positive that don't
do that because I'm gonna do something's
gonna happen yes yes like that's my fear
like let my son down like I'm always
like bro listen to me
the only thing that you can do to let
them down is by continuing down the path
of thinking that you're bad right yeah
yeah I can't I don't want him to grow up
like that you know like being like me
like I don't know where she don't but
let me tell you because I've watched
this I've watched this transpire cuz I'm
cuz I'm old for 44 I got some real
[ __ ] emotional wisdom what's gonna end
up happening is if your child or
children end up having similar DNA to
you you're gonna feel so bad that you're
gonna actually resent them and have like
a worse relief like you'll have a good
relationship with the children that take
your wife's DNA and you'll have a bad
relationship with the children that take
your DNA cuz it's gonna be painful to
you cuz you're gonna be like [ __ ] I pass
that on to her or him so I'm out no I
can't do that you can't do that yeah bro
I'm really proud of you to be at this
place at this young of an age to be
self-aware enough to know what's brewing
and to have the courage to come on here
and talk to me about this [ __ ]
that's game-changing you open when I
tell you you're close because the only
thing that holds people back is hiding
[ __ ] right right and right now you just
told tens of thousands of people about
your [ __ ] yeah yeah it's just like that
bad dude like I'm like I have to tell
someone that actually like you know cuz
I got to tell other people like my wife
I want to say other people I mean like
my wife and like
you know she's just like I feel like
maybe hearing it from her is not as good
because I'm I of course you're just
gonna try to like you know bring me up
and make me feel better because I'm your
husband
you know so of course like I feel like
her answer is not as genuine maybe but
it probably doesn't Kerry's
automatically think that yeah you listen
you default into the angle the
conspiracy
you must love conspiracy [ __ ]
documentaries like you that's like you
know like like that's where you're at
yeah and what's so interesting in the
theme of this show is now you know why
you're the one that looks at other
things and tries to tear people down
yeah I mean we I really believe as we go
through this period of time in American
history specifically and really in the
world where hate and negativity have
definitely risen I believe that we're
gonna get into mental health issues and
get into you know parenting structures
and like and and the and and the the and
what I what I'm really worried about is
that a lot of people that are that think
they're kind and good people are
actually shaming people and start
instead of trying to help right yeah I
agree with that I think we're she good
they're on the receiving end of that yes
yes yeah yeah I feel like you know holy
[ __ ] dude I don't even think about it
like how you were saying it you know
like maybe I just you know got a I think
I got it like work on it more like on a
daily basis and just exercise it more
you know I'm trying to change that cuz
damn like it's I didn't think about it I
don't know I didn't think about it like
I'm scared of stuff you know I've just
thought about it like i'm just- you know
and like i just don't like people that
much you know and this and that
yeah no no you don't like yourself yeah
yeah no that's probably you don't like i
do i really don't like how i like I hate
that mind that's right but the good news
is you can fix it I didn't like that I
didn't have you know muscles and you
know like and that I was not healthy for
my heart and like I was gonna like and I
change in and when I tell you working
out and eating right did not come
natural to me at all right so I changed
I figured it out I got a babysitter a
trainer and I figured out the system you
just have to figure out your system
right maybe you maybe you have to listen
to positivity on podcast 24 hours a day
that's what Oh every single day like
other people I appreciate it but like
you know like and and maybe me like bro
you have to watch this video like every
day ya know I probably this is like the
biggest moments like top 5 like best
things like bro you are just perfectly
cliche in so many your actions I see so
many young people who have this
framework get married early as soon as
they find somebody super positive yeah
yeah it's right first for her yeah I
would I really like I wish I could be
like you like I wish I could just think
everything's gonna be fine and like you
know like I always tell her that because
it's just such a good you know like you
know instead of making it selfish and
say I wish I could be like you maybe
what you can do is make it accomplished
you're making it about yourself when you
say that to her oh [ __ ] not anything
what you what you what you might want to
change that to and this is where
semantics of words matter maybe you say
to her what's her name uh no I mean no I
mean yeah no I mean I admire your
optimism and positivity now all of a
sudden you're giving her a compliment
because when you say to her I wish that
I could be like you she's not taking
that as a compliment
she sees that as you being selfish about
what you wish your about you in that
sentence yeah that's true yeah I'm
saying I wish I was you know yeah and
what you know and and what you're doing
is you're subconsciously again saying
hey like feel bad for me right
instead of propping her up you're asking
her for another hand you almost there's
a subconscious guilt of like you got
lucky with DNA I didn't and what's gonna
happen with her she's gonna build
resentment for you over time right no I
agree I agree 100% with that yeah bro I
really really believe in you Thank You
Man
I appreciate it like you know I don't
normally talk about this with anyone you
know normally like I tried like I said
with theory but I was like man Gary's
like the perfect person you just put
this on you know and just see like what
you know what his response would be -
it's like I've been trying to talk to
you for the longest time dude like I'm
telling you three years like I would be
any all-time like when you took out with
I came out with this messaging service
I've messed at you and stuff you know
you actually responded like six months
ago
like you were like hey what's up cuz I
was like I'm like I hope you see this
you know and then you just spawned it
back to it I was like [ __ ] yeah like I
saved it you know so like just I swear
to God on everything in my body I
genuinely think you can win this game
Thank You Man I really like its life Kay
need to hear that from you know what I'm
saying like it's so please be honest
that you were wound you're hurt you're
not bad
you're good without injury right yeah I
just didn't realize that I didn't think
about it I didn't I didn't you know I
guess I guess cuz I'm young too so it
kind of like you don't think about that
stuff like you know and now I'm like
damn that's probably what it is maybe
something happened to me you know like
it just kind of like yeah but like don't
and I don't think it's usually it's more
of a systematic you know culture like
it's very likely that one of your
parents is exactly the same way and
instead of resenting your parent you can
feel bad for them too right
you can have compassion for them instead
of now going into a place of like you
know what [ __ ] you mom Gary's right I'm
[ __ ] you no no you can go into a place
of compassion because it's likely that
her mom did that or your dad's dad did
that you understand yeah yeah yeah I
agree with that yeah so it's important
that you realize it's up you need to
realize that you're strong enough to
change it for everyone right digging in
and drawing the line and making it a
fight is gonna do nothing
yeah and you think like also like what
you surround yourself with also kind of
affects you to kind of like 100 percent
right yeah of course I believe that it's
why I [ __ ] work so hard to put out so
much free content yeah I'm trying to be
a positive force for people that aren't
fortunate enough to have something and I
have a unique
education style and a and a human
element that clicks for some people that
because because I think they can taste
the lack of interest of anything other
than the X you know like I'm not looking
for anything that's why I said when I
first started watching your videos I
didn't think like you've had an angle I
was like holy [ __ ] this guy's like and
it's I think it's cuz you called people
in their [ __ ] you know and like
funny you know xx hear that a lot from
me from people and they like that you
know what's funny I don't I I think even
the tone of this conversation I I just
want to help right yeah and that's like
you know you always preach that it
really does like work that's what I said
like you do change like I said even in
three years I feel like I have gotten
better you know maybe I've gotten worse
actually that isolate people like myself
from people more but I have gotten
better in the sense of like you know now
like with YouTube and like other stuff
like that I'm more confident that I will
be able to make that work you know like
that's like my other thing that I don't
like you you need to realize that those
people aren't bad or have an angle it's
that you're scared cuz you're not
emotionally strong to be let down
yeah you're cutting you're cutting them
out to protect yourself the way to
really win quote-unquote is for you to
get comfortable with being let down and
realizing that's not a reflection of you
right no I agree with that that's that's
awesome that's like what I needed to
keep okay like a deliberate bro thank
you so much man I really really
appreciate it dude let's listen to me
over the next year a million people
gonna watch this video just remember
that means that cutting people out or
trolling someone or waking up like
you're not gonna be able to live anymore
tricking people you're not tricking
anyone anymore right use that as a
positive
ya know I didn't trust me I like I said
maybe like hearing it from you since
like I've always looked up to you for a
long time and like you know like I said
in the last three years I was like you
know 19 20 you know 21 so like I feel
like I kind of grew up and cuz you know
like in those stages of life you do grow
up to a certain extent you know like and
I feel like watching you as like
my role model has kind of like you know
helped me a lot so now I'm actually
talking to you which is still crazy and
listening to you say that you know my
role model it's like holy [ __ ] like you
know yeah I need to change I need to do
something like I can't keep being like
this this is I'm telling you right now
what most excites me is I know you can
thank you so much if you knew the power
and strength it took for you to be
honest on this video now living life and
being okay with Ricki if you like steals
your money or like something bad about
your wife and you being a bigger person
like you can't imagine now trying to
forgive one of your parents or an uncle
or something you know I don't want to
dive too deep it might be something even
more extreme than just a negative
atmosphere it might be some real deep
[ __ ] forgiveness is the [ __ ] key to a
whole new life ya know I haven't
practiced that yet in my life if you
know like I have it really I'm not a
forgetful person so maybe I should that
comes that comes out of your own
insecurities yeah forgiveness and being
the bigger person and kindness is the
[ __ ] ultimate strength yeah no that's
I need it I need to do it I didn't start
doing it I really do I really believe
you I really think you can I really
think you can at 25 minutes late for a
huge client meet oh my god dude I'm so
sorry no no what I'm what I want you to
hear is that the reason I'm this late is
because I feel this moment so much and
I'm also super aware of how raw and real
we went and how many hundreds of people
right now watching our live in your
exact life and this this thing I
genuinely believe is the seed of so much
of the things that are anxious in our
society and I desperately desperately
want to be one of the forces to [ __ ]
help cut this thing out of our bodies ya
know I mean we need it you know like the
people that are like Alexis you have an
Instagram yes because I want this
community DM you encourage you and I
want you to make some
friends what's your what's your so um
it's Alexis sis narrow that's the way
yeah just a way like my name is and then
underscore at the end right right after
yeah yeah right there
somebody found it doesn't found it I
guess that's awesome holy [ __ ] you are
567 568 now I love you so much you like
cars I love cars that's been my passion
since I was like six years old
alright 568 vaynernation this would mean
the world to me I want to see this
number completely [ __ ] explode and I
want every one of you to DM this man
something positive I want please please
thank you so much I appreciate that so
much very man thank you so much let's
just listen to me please do me one honor
please listen to this whole entire thing
I think it was like 30 minutes yeah
often off okay thank you so much like
literally work out every morning and
listen to this where while you're
brushing their teeth every morning every
morning I'm telling you man yeah thank
you so much dude I will listen to it
I'll make trust me this is like a huge
deal to me like it's a huge it's a huge
deal for me too thank you so much
holy [ __ ] like I didn't I honestly
wasn't even gonna talk to you about this
like I was like I had a whole different
question but then I was like talking to
you and I'm like damn like he's
absolutely like as real as it gets man
you know so I was like I'm just gonna
lay it all out you know I was like
Alexis you helped more people today than
most people ever get to help in their
entire life you're a good kid you're not
nagging you you're not bad
they were mislabeled bro you make me cry
dude like well you're mislabeled you're
miss labeling yourself to yourself yeah
you're a wonderful [ __ ] human who has
an injury has a vulnerability and has to
completely address that and change the
way you talk and think and practice that
you want you want a real prescription go
reach out to everybody in your phone go
to your phone right now and look at from
A to Z and text people and say you're
sorry and I
you damn yeah that takes real strength
yeah yeah yeah there's some people that
I'm like you know I would never want to
see this guy's name again you know like
I don't know why like it's because
because you're insecure
yeah no I'm when you and when you do
that if you get the courage to do it
when they reply [ __ ] you understand yeah
compassion comes from enormous strength
thank you so much man like like I said
this is this moment right here I think
it was definitely a hundred percent
life-changing for me this is definitely
like like I said I've been doing better
in these last three years but I feel
like that boost that I need a hundred
percent thank you so much love you I'm
sorry for what sorry for you late this
is the best nine minutes late in my
entire life
I'm so humbled to have this moment with
you what we just did here will forever
bring value to human beings I believe it
in the depths of my [ __ ] being thank
you dude that's like that means the
world to me that honestly it really
means the world to me dude this is what
I needed thank you so much Barry you're
welcome brother how's your day man thank
you to the way Dustin
very very very powerful that really
matters that last one man yeah you know
like that's the whole game that right
there is the whole game I see in the
world
I feel very similar like there's a lot
of people in my world that I've kind of
dropped and I've wanted to reach out I'm
just afraid that they're gonna be like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you are like whatever
loser or something like that
right I just don't know that well that
don't do things for other people's
reactions do them for you and for the
Karma
and even if they tell you [ __ ] you know
always know where you stood cuz right
now they think you stand with [ __ ] you
and you might be doing a blessing for
them because that may inspire them to do
it for somebody else even if they don't
reply to you yeah there's nothing more
noble than I'm sorry and if you can do
it an audio or video where they can not
lose the tone of the written word but
it's even more powerful man
duster can do it but you're here with me
now like come on you can do that should
yeah you're right it's good something
out more good is good you know it's what
we [ __ ] need man this is it's time
we've gone too long with not making this
the way we go you're gonna feel lighter
I mean I did start like I had someone
that me something to like make fun of
someone and I was like i DM them and
like hey someone sent this to me to like
make fun of you and I was like no I'm
not doing that like I will actually
respect what you just put out so I just
want to say that and any bad taste you
having about me from the past I just
want to apologize for that too I mean I
didn't reply but at least I know no not
tried executed you're not doing it for
him to reply you
brought value to him and you brought
value to yourself you won with that I'm
so proud of you man
that's a humongous thanks right down the
list from [ __ ] a A to Z Z and you're
in your address book write down the list
watch boy listen
that means you were hurting yeah I know
you well enough to understand it do it
it's so nice to do it's so good you're a
different man man yeah see you tomorrow
in T with Gary D the people that are
gonna win over the next five to seven
years are gonna be very comfortable in
control the process requires sacrifice
all your actions have to been mapped
back back back back back back nobody
gives a [ __ ] about where you grew up
the whole game of scaling the unscalable
it's [ __ ] hard work it's being
respectful it's being a good person who
that that's just a good idea it's there
the flipping is there this helps right
here there's $400 minute I stay my lady
like real [ __ ] tight but you can't be
crippled everybody here judging
themselves you're looking at what's in
front of you right now
you're losing cuz you're laying in your
bed looking at somebody's [ __ ]
glamorous photoshopped picture of them
doing something cool and you're envious
and you're jealous and you're impatient
and it's crippling you're upside let me
just say one more time if you're
confused what I just said I say put your
[ __ ] flag on the ground up who the
[ __ ] you are whoever provides the most
value always you're entering the
greatest five year window of your life
my only answer today or anybody like
it's just like try [ __ ] shut your
business down and go work for an apparel
company behaviour nobody you've ever met
got there without the hard work
so you better get your speed up you
better work harder you better work
smarter you can't Google stuff you're
not gonna be able to do anything that
I'm telling Gary
TV like hell to check me out
hope you enjoy